what's going on guys my name is David
Tom ehm welcome back to the channel one
second right now in 2019 there are
thousands of different vices on the
market that you can spend days on days
or days looking at all the different
options and trying to find the best one
for you
so if you didn't recognize it from the
thumbnail already the mouse I'm talking
about is the Logitech MX master 2's
mouse I've had my fair share of computer
mice over the years and I can say that
hands-down this Mouse brings me the most
joy out of everything I've ever
purchased for a computer before now
there's lots of things about this mouse
that make it so unique it's so powerful
besides the simple features like
Bluetooth connectivity and also adapter
connectivity to use with any computer
regardless of age or compatibility now
like I've said I've owned some unique
things in the past including a cyborg
collection of Mouse's these mice were
deconstructive and also weighted that
you could use in any situation and
adjust to any different hand and a
different hand shape
however I had two of these mice in space
of two years the first one was a
wireless mouse with interchangeable
batteries that died in about a year and
the batteries cost more than a mouse to
actually replace so unfortunately I
scrapped that Mouse the second version
was a wired mouse because I didn't want
to go down that same path and well I
don't know about you guys but a wired
mouse is really impractical the cables
go everywhere and it just looks really
messy and really cluttered so I decided
to upgrade to Logitech MX master 2's
Mouse now the first thing I love about
this mouse isn't very unique but it is
the simple economics of it so regardless
of the size of your hand it can
basically fit around the shape of the
mouse perfectly and the mouth does come
in two options it comes in the basic
standard flat laying down Mouse or also
comes in a vertical option where your
wrist is constantly in a more neutral
position now if you're thinking why
economics so important well personally I
spend about twelve to fourteen hours a
day sitting behind my desk working away
and after a while with a bad mouse and a
bad keyboard your wrists really start to
get sore and the next day you've got
pains and your fingers and your joints
and if you think about that over a
prolonged period of time
well ten twelve twenty years down the
track you're not going to be able to
really use your wrist so much so
personally I'm investing in something
that will hopefully reduce the severity
of that effect down the long term if not
completely remove it in its entirety now
the second thing I love about this mouse
is something that I didn't really know
when I first the mouse and wasn't
surprised to me and it is by far the
best feature on this Mouse and I love it
using it so much every single day
basically
the scroll wheel is forever scrolling
now that may not sound like a big deal
to you guys but if you think about it
you're doing this all day every day just
scrolling whereas now you can do one
scroll and the mouse literally just
continues to scroll for about 15 to 20
seconds so to just simply demonstrate in
fact of how how impressive this feature
is I'm gonna put this math back down
inside a walk away and make myself cup
of tea while it's still scrolling ready
spin
[Music]
all right cup of tea made and the mouse
is just about stop scrolling now the
third and final feature why I think this
mouse is the king of all Mouse's on the
market at the moment is the fact that
it's super productive and helps you with
your workflow now you might be thinking
it's just a mouse how can it do that
well if you're somebody like me who work
for the desktop most the time and then
also has a laptop on the go and
sometimes forgets to drag all their
files off their laptop to the Google
Drive to a USB or anything like that
this Mouse makes it super simple and
super productive to get all your files
from one computer to another in the same
room without having to use a hundred
different masses at the same time and
just juggling with all these different
things so let me explain that in a bit
more clarity basically what this Mouse
does it allows you to connect to three
computers simultaneously so for example
say I have my desktop behind me set up
working your way using this Mouse as my
primary Mouse and then I have my laptop
on the side open ready to go usually
like most of us we'd have to use this
mouse on the desktop go over to the
laptop use the trackpad or use the
separate Mouse that you have for that
one
to get your files plug in a USB or
transfer the files to the Google Drive
with the Logitech MX master 2's Mouse
you can simply connect the mouse to both
devices so that you can use the laptop
as almost like a third screen so all you
have to do is drag the mouse over across
the edge of the screen it will
automatically connect to your laptop and
you can start using your laptop with the
same mouse now the added benefit if you
have a Logitech keyboard that has the
same compatibility you can also use the
keyboard directly with the laptop as
well so you don't need a separate
keyboard either
which is a fantastic use of the feature
so it's all well and good that you can
get the mouse across from one computer
to another but it also has the added
benefit of being able to copy and paste
files across from the two devices so if
I've forgotten to file on my laptop I
can quickly scroll across right click
copy go back to my desktop right-click
paste and it's done I don't have to
worry about it
transferring across the cloud or going
into a USB or anything like that
now there is one shortfall to this mess
and that's just one of my personal
opinions basically I would have loved to
have seen this mouse come in a matte
black version at the moment it only
comes in this deep dark gray with this
combination graphite texture on the side
which still looks super cool and super
unique and doesn't get any fingerprints
like a matte black one would but if you
guys have been watching my videos you
know that I love the matte black so much
I always black in my videos I have a
collection of matte black watches first
link in the description if you want to
check it out and it is just one of my
favorite accessory colors at the moment
so it is a bit of a downfall that
doesn't come in that back color but hey
not the worst thing in the world
especially for a mouse that has all
these super cool unique features now if
you clicked on this video to check out
this masters other features well to
quickly run through them guys it's
connected by bluetooth and also via a
Logitech adapter it's charged directly
through a USB micro cable unfortunately
it is not a USB see that would have been
another feature that would have been
great just to kind of reduce the number
of cables everybody has to hold the
mouse is incredibly quick and incredibly
quiet it does take a little bit of time
to get used to the actual shape but
however it is super economic super
comfortable and by far the hands-down
the best mouse I've owned to date and
that's it for me guys I hope you enjoyed
the video as always make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20-19 style I publish a new video every
single Monday so make sure you check
back in with me and I'll see you next
week